face book life setup and how to use for
business
the final face book tool that businesses
can use is face book life which
basically allows you to livestream video
to your Facebook audience life streaming
started on Twitter a few years ago
through periscope it soon moved to
YouTube and Facebook and is now a really
exciting communication tool to connect
instantly with your audience life
streaming has caught the media world by
surprise I can now be at a live concert
and stream it life to my Facebook
friends where do media rights fit into
this the industry is still trying to
come up with answers fact is that
Facebook life allows you to start your
own live TV program and broadcast it
instantly to a global Facebook audience
and on top of this Facebook loves you to
use Facebook life and will reward you
for using it by giving your facebook
life post a higher organic reach
Facebook life has lots of opportunities
for businesses
it gives natural engagement by people
liking and commenting during the live
broadcast and Facebook gives you lots of
opportunities to promote the life event
before and after the live broadcasts at
the end of the broadcast Facebook will
ask you if you want to save the
broadcast and post it on your feet often
this leads to lots of additional views
and engagements on this side you can see
where in the world Facebook live
broadcasts are happening right now you
also see a lot of life activity in
Southeast Asia so let's look at some of
the features Facebook Life covers three
aspects of communication first it allows
you to have live conversations with your
followers and Facebook life turns these
conversations in very engaging
experiences with likes and emoticons
flowing over the screen as they come in
and comments showing up as well second
you can turn your life broadcasts into a
visual story like
you want to tell it you can add filters
colors texts overlays etc adding
augmented reality features is not far
away and thirdly you can target
audiences in multiple ways for your
broadcasts and on top of that Facebook
will give your live broadcast a higher
than average organic reach Old Spice
Brasil is a great example of a Facebook
live campaign they did a 2-day live
broadcast to put their antiperspirant
products to the test they turn it into a
big marketing campaign with which they
reached over nine million people with
the time of the broadcast there are many
ways businesses can use Facebook life
it's a great tool for promoting your
products or services you can do live
tutorials or product launches it can be
used to support your live events you can
do a broadcast during your event and
interview an expert who attends the
event it can also be used to support
your customers you can do a live Q&A ask
for feedback hold the webinar and
Facebook life also lends itself for
sharing news announce a sale or organize
a sales party lots of opportunities it
may take a while to build traction with
your broadcasts but if you can maintain
the momentum you can generate plenty of
coverage and engagement a good way to
maintain engagement is to turn your life
broadcasts into recurring episodes
weekly or monthly so you can build your
campaign around this and build up a
library of great content
it is very easy to start your Facebook
live video when you are on your company
page what you do you click on the
publish button on your mobile and then
in the different options you see one of
them is live video you click on your
life video you immediately see what you
want on the the screen you can have
different background settings if you
want to different filters you can select
where you want to to post and you can
then basically click start the live
button when you start a live button your
life you can still add different effects
you can invite people you can chat and
basically we are now live if I now would
go to my other phone and let me just
quickly do that I will go to Facebook
and I will go to the Facebook page so
off simply learn and I can see that
Facebook lets me go here yeah so I go to
the simply simply learn business page
and I can then see that the video is
life on the page from simply learn and
here I can then engage with the page you
can also see here in the screen that I
have one viewer and that is me in this
case here you can also see that I can
like and this is I think a really cool
feature of the Facebook live which shows
you the engagement that is happening
during the broadcast it can be a thumbs
up it can be a heart it can be a smiley
face and I've seen companies do polls
which give me a smiley face if you like
the product give me a sad face if you're
not happy with the with the product and
then you can count a number of likes
that come in them in that way you can
also see who is watching and that's in
this case is more camp man I can then
also put in a comment to this post and I
can just say hi and post it and that
comment that will show up
on the feed as well so way very engaging
very interactive process to run your
Facebook live broadcasts so when I click
finish then what Facebook will do is
will save the video and it will then
give you the option to save it on your
newsfeed on your timeline you can upload
it in high-definition
so when you save it on your timeline
then when you can share it straight away
or you can save it on your disk
I click share and now you see that on my
business page in a minute the page the
the live broadcast will show up actually
it's already shown up here and you can
then see who was on the the video yep
you see the comment that came in and you
can see the video and you soon see the
engagement in the other video as well so
very powerful concept to run Facebook
live broadcasts hi there if you like
this video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here